hi everyone i'm jolene thiel and i'm
jeevna hegde and we're both customer
engineers at google cloud
and we're excited to have you back at
our technical guide for startups where
we are creating a series of videos for
technical enablement to start build and
grow your businesses successfully and
sustainably on google cloud in our
previous video we spoke about cost
optimization and billing and moving on
to the final episode of the start series
today we'll be sharing with you more
about support packages and customer care
at google cloud in this video we're
going to do an overview of customer care
portfolio understand what the scope of
google cloud support is and the
different support options offered to you
by google cloud we will also do a demo
on how to purchase support and how to
create a support case we will then be
wrapping up our start series and look at
what we have next for you in store
so without any further ado let's get
started
cloud support is definitely crucial as
it provides you with the support that
you may need across many aspects of your
startup journey such as firstly product
usage questions and technical help
feature requests unexpected product
behavior and last but not least billing
and administration questions and we want
to be able to give you the incredible
experience and comprehensive support as
you build on google cloud to meet the
needs of customers and deliver a better
experience google cloud has
re-envisioned a customer care portfolio
the vision places customers at the
center of the model so you don't have to
shuffle between different support teams
or systems a flexible service so you can
choose the right offering that is
perfect for your business needs and an
ongoing partnership so your people can
get answers to all their questions
simplify and streamline your support
experience with the google cloud
customer care portfolio which has a
scalable set of offerings built around
your needs
choose from the core offerings of basic
standard enhanced and premium and there
are also additional value added services
available for enhanced and premium and
will be going through each offering in
detail starting with basic this is the
support tier you will receive when you
sign up on google cloud you can unveil
this offering at no cost via chat phone
or cases but only for billing related
issues additionally please check the
link in the description box below to get
the price and details for the other
offerings next we have standard support
a simple and flexible way to ensure that
your workloads are running smoothly on
google cloud standard support is a paid
support offering highly recommended for
small and medium enterprises looking to
begin their journey on google cloud this
offering helps you to easily build
troubleshoot and test standard enables
you to receive technical help from
google experts through creating cases
with a four hour response time for cases
with high impact and a overall eight
five availability next up we have
enhanced support which delivers rapid
response times and additional services
to boost your productivity and help you
run the cloud efficiently there is both
case and phone support for technical
issues with a one hour response time
there is 24x5 availability overall and
24x7 for critical issues you can also
have add-ons or value-add services like
we mentioned earlier like technical
account advisor service and event
management and the final offering is
premium support premium support is the
highest value support offering supplying
you with incredibly fast response times
there are many features that come with
having premium support some of which
include having a named technical account
manager having new product previews
operational health reviews training
resources as well as an event management
service
there is also case and phone support for
technical issues as well as third party
technology support there is also a
15-minute response time for critical
impact cases as well as 24 7 support for
critical impact issues moving on to a
demonstration let's go over how to
purchase support within your google
cloud console go to your google cloud
console and you can see your dashboard
now move to the navigation menu
hover over support and click on overview
here's the overview dashboard for your
support page
go to the support information card and
select view support offerings
under standard support for example click
on buy now in the drop down list select
the google cloud organization resource
for the offering and then click on
continue in the drop down list here
select the cloud billing account for the
standard support base fee read and agree
to the terms of service
and then click on complete purchase and
that's it you have yourself your
standard support tier it works very
similarly for enhanced as well as
premium support
next moving on to the second demo i'll
be showing you how you can create a
support case in your console first go to
your console and navigate to the support
page as a support user as you can see in
the console you can create cases through
various channels depending on your
support package in the cases tab if you
have previously created any cases you
should be able to see a list of them
over here and from here to create a new
case simply click on create case and
following that all you need to do is to
complete the required fields first you
need to give your case a title
and following that give it a priority
ranging from p1 to p4 with p1 being the
most critical
thirdly all you need to do is to select
a category
as well as a component and last but not
least all you have to do is to fill out
the description as you can see after
selecting the category as well as the
component a description template has
been created for you and you simply need
to add in that information at the same
time on the right hand side of the
screen you can see the help assistant
dynamically providing some useful
articles which are relevant to your case
and could be helpful to explore and
finally in the last step you can click
submit to submit the case in this demo
i'm not gonna do so but you can when
creating a new support case
after you submit the case you will be
redirected to the case page where you
can easily make any form of edits to the
attributes add on any further comments
as well as upload attachments to the
case and that concludes our overview on
support packages do check out the links
in the description box below to find out
more about customer care and support at
google cloud we're so happy to be
successfully concluding our first
segment of the startup journey which was
the start series let's do a recap of our
journey we kicked off the series with
the launch video where we did an
overview of the series we then learned
how to get started on google cloud with
an introduction to the resource
hierarchy cloud ins and lots of
demonstrations then you learned how you
can deploy your applications with cloud
run for application development you also
saw how to configure google kubernetes
engine how you could build and leverage
google compute engine as well as manage
your networking configurations
we then did the database configurations
for the same application so you know how
the flow for a single application works
we learned how firebase can be used to
build improve and grow your application
and learned how to manage your ci cd
deployments on google cloud we also went
over logging monitoring and more with
cloud operations for your deployed
applications and following that we also
went through billing as well as cost
optimization and finally for today's
episode which is the final episode of
the start series we also went through
customer care support as well as the
support packages available to provide
you with the integrated care experience
and with that that concludes our start
series we're so thankful that you joined
us on this journey we're really excited
to share with you more in our next
segment the build series where we are
going to help startups that have already
launched on google cloud to optimize and
scale let us know in the comment section
below what you thought of the series
don't forget to like and subscribe to
our youtube channel and stay tuned for
more such amazing content
and that's a wrap thank you and we can't
wait to see you in our next series bye
for now
[Music]